the cost of living is a blank in every
platform each size has a configured down
from the Industrial Revolution to
industrial turn
elections have defined the nature of the
economy the average man hasn't got their
full election fever yet but the attempt
is arising from Thatcher to Blair - a
starett so what does this election say
about this country when Labour wins
about the nature of work
our jobs pay of Rights always being one
or two paychecks away from disaster
circle people's priorities investing in
the NHS getting more police on the
streets investing in our schools we can
do that and the future of the economy
this election isn't just about braixen
it's about much more than that
the fact is about an economic shift that
could change the destiny of the UK
you
what are we down in Street earlier this
month low paid fast-food workers
demonstrates they want higher pay and
more rights the fight back against
precarious work and zero hours contracts
writ large but coming alongside a
general election there is an added
urgency I'll invite you and Labour's
Shadow Chancellor says he wants to tip
the balance from the bosses to the
workers from day one in that first
budget we need to ensure that we we put
money into people's pockets and lift
people out of poverty and give them a
standard of living so the 10 pounds in
our real living wage we've got emergency
reforms of universal credit that we want
to bring forward as well to tackle
poverty and interests I introduced a
real safety net and then we start
looking at our infrastructure investment
plans here in his offices John McDonald
has spent the past few years preparing
what he hopes will be a revolution with
ideas so radical he thinks they could
change the nature of this country
altogether how do we trigger that
investment alongside but how much of
this is just retro socialism
on the other side of town another
protest support staff demonstrating
against their bosses it's a similar
story low pay not enough rights or
recognition
we're working hard for my money from
Lebanon for me better for have a good
life like everybody think here like you
would like me but while this might look
like 1970s industrial activism it's not
quite the same if you think back to the
defining images of the 20th century in
terms of economics it was all about the
relationship between government and
industry at the mining none of the
miners strike in the 1980s both here in
a sense you have the 21st century
analogy it's not about manufacturing
it's about services it's about
outsourcing it's about the gig economy
it's about globalization as a whole and
that is the battleground on which the
elections being formed so while in the
80s everyone recognized the battleground
between right and left these days it's
become a gray area for the Tories
to are proposing an increase in the
minimum wage taking it beyond even where
ed Miliband wanted it a few years ago
you should be led by the evidence and
look at the recent change in the
national living wage when I've announced
that that we're going to get it to 10
pounds 50 and we're going to reduce the
age years eligible from 21 and above
it's conservatists doing that it will
help end low pay forever
in this country there certainly there's
been an evolution and policies that
traditionally might have seen very much
of the left whether that's kind of you
know living wages whether that's caps on
energy prices they are now at the heart
of your manifesto in your policies which
is it's an interesting shift isn't it
well based on evidence yeah there are
new things that we're doing to support
the British people but at the same time
our our basic approach that is sound
public finances supporting free
enterprise supporting entrepreneurs none
of that has changed and you contrast
that today with labor it's a is the new
is black and white except it's not not
quite Audra McDonald you know
all Markey Labour Party policies but
they're also now machi Tory Party
policies aren't they they've shifted
onto your ground haven't they not on any
significant way I think they're
tokenistic Lee and making the right
noises at the moment but not delivering
on any scale is that actually do you
thing well so virtually in the sense of
a sort of humanizing the debate the
manifesto a blitz of policy a splurge of
spending promises from labor labor is on
your side and the Lib Dems so that
everyone can live secure happy and
fulfilling life and a big surprise
here's the kicker we can do all these
things without raising our income tax
dat for national insurance contributions
that's our guarantee having talked about
the expending the Tories suddenly were
trashed were they heading back to the
right or are they seeking a different
identity we are a Conservative Party the
new believes in keeping the economy
strong and and as with conservative
parties in the past that is very much
means having sound money use strong
public finances keeping boring and dead
under control and also supporting free
enterprise and borrowing more well
boring within responsible levels and as
long as that's going that extra boring
is going into economic infrastructure
and that's the key distinction here all
the parties want to borrow more and
spend more but the Tories want to borrow
only to invest in things like rail and
road projects labour want to reshape the
nature of the state yet have we both
forgotten the very people who might most
need them every election the parties
devise these catchy monikers about who
they want to vote for them Monday oh man
Workington man just about managing the
idea is that if they come up with the
right policies these people will flock
to them but maybe this time around
that's not quite right because there are
many hard-pressed low-income families
who are simply so disaffected that they
don't have a political home at all
people like Lou a few years ago she was
homeless now she's working two jobs but
still can't afford to rent privately
instead she's living in a holiday home
we can't show you where because she's
not supposed to be living there
permanently and having a stable home you
know if if you've if you've lost that
you know what that feels like it
undermines everything else she is one of
the millions of Britons barely keeping
their heads above the financial waters
last week I was worried because I was
thinking christmas is coming I can't
afford Christmas it roads who you are as
a person makes you feel inadequate
that's one of the hardest things as well
as the shame do you feel the this
government or indeed just kind of
politicians in general recognize that
there is a problem at least now they of
course absolutely of course they know
then they're not blind to what's going
on at all but while labour want to ditch
universal credit none of the major
parties is planning to reverse all of
those austerity era welfare cuts
actually the party which goes furthest
in that respect is the Lib Dems who want
to seize on territory neglected by the
big two I think what is notable about
this election is all parties are talking
about spending more and that's probably
left the electorate quite confused well
in service and Boris Johnson are chasing
labour votes they're chasing those seats
in the Midlands and the north basically
you've got a choice of
party at leaves and free trade that
believes in markets the libel Democrats
or you've got the Conservative Party who
wants to put up trade barriers who wants
to pull us out of markets and you've got
the Labour Party who've gone to the left
who believe the state should run
everything now that is a unique
political backdrop to the economic
debate and I think that shows that Lula
Democrats are the party of business are
the party with the best economic
policies business for a long time a key
constituency for all the parties feels
more ignored than ever
frustration exasperation I think the
relationship between business from
politics is isn't is not at its highest
point you know I think it's got an all
day long way to go and one of the
reasons for that is that party politics
have been you know right before so we do
need a reset
we need a reset frankly in the interest
of the country because the economy has
slipped into the slow lane of course
what business fears most assign brexit
is a return to the 1970s and especially
old-school labour interventionism but
actually some of what John McDonough was
proposing is different including
experiment in localism that goes back to
his days on the Greater London council
it was about making sure you devolve
powers and resources to enable change to
take place and the investment in public
services and it was about using public
procurement at the local and regional
level to maximize the impact of that and
also to maximise the control of it
to see what that means considered what
they're doing here in Preston where work
is underway to renovate the marketplace
in the center of town those diggers are
from a local firm the workers are local
workers and that's not a coincidence
it's the whole point the council tries
to procure work from nearby businesses
which isn't the way it used to be so it
would have been the kind of the big
names yeah taking you know taking money
and it wouldn't necessarily have stayed
at the community yeah it would have been
filtered out the community but also a
lot of the lot of people who are now
working in these jobs potentially they
might have been brought from outside
when Matthew Brown brought in this new
models employment here was lower than
the UK average now it's higher PwC
recently named it as Britain's most
improved city and the striking thing is
you don't just have to be a Labour
supporter to want to think a bit more
local this is actually spreading beyond
high political realms now to be honest
so even one or two conservative counts
as to their merit in this that consensus
with the new ideas shared by all the
parties whether it's more localism the
minimum wage or more investment spending
means this election isn't quite as stark
as you might have thought the
conventional wisdom says there's never
been as big a divide between the major
parties as there is at this election but
what if that isn't quite right because
well it's certainly true labour has
shifted quite a long way to the left
look at the Tories and economic terms
you've got more spending more borrowing
more intervention they've gone that
direction - you could make the case
actually there is less choice than a
normal user elections because the entire
electoral battle ground has shifted to
the left
so whoever wins this election there will
be a blitz in spending and a move away
from austerity the main difference is
just how big and the main question is
whether it will really bridge the divide
between our politicians and the country
they serve